Zendaya may be locking lips with Tom
Holland but there's another famous actor
who would gladly take his place things
got wild on these sets I'm talking first
kisses that ended up in marriage to
Starburst breath all the way to the
infamous actor who not only locked lips
with her famous co-star but also his
wife the tea is hot no shade to our girl
Vanessa Hudgins but Zac Efron said his
best on screen kiss was with Zendaya and
the reason behind it actually has to do
with the characters they played in the
greatest showman the tension that was
built up between them was a huge Factor
not really the actual kiss itself
because I don't know if you've noticed
but Zac Efron does a ton of on-screen
kisses this might be my favorite Kiss I
think ever everyone watching including
Zach and Zendaya is rooting for these
characters to finally have their moments
it pays off yeah for the audience and
for people watching oh finally and
speaking of forbidden love let's talk
about it girl and Lonely Boy pen Badgley
and Blake Lively dated and broke up
during their time on Gossip Girl so
because of that reason Penn describes
her as his best and worst on-screen kiss
talk about drama they broke up months
before the season 2 finale and had to
continue their characters on again
off-again love affair or four more
seasons and well they kept it a secret
from the crew because they didn't want
their personal relationship to bleed
over into their working relationships
they were absolute professionals about
it and to be honest their breakup was
totally amicable and they're both
happily married to other people now and
I'm sure most of you probably know that
but now I get to do this fun little
segue where I talk about Blake Lively's
husband so this is actually pretty funny
co-star humor and Blake Lively is
clearly a great sport when Ryan Reynolds
was asked on Twitter about his on-screen
kiss with Anna Kendrick in their 2014
movie The Voices he quickly responded
like taking your your face to Awesome
Town literally the most dad joke
response but I know we're all here for
it and Anna Kendrick couldn't help but
jump on the fun with her response that
is the Anna Kendrick train guarantee
with local stops in awkwardville and
tolerable Shire but who knew Anna
Kendrick would be taking Blake Lively to
awesometown four years later in a simple
favor now this one definitely was no
surprise well his breath smelling like
Starburst kind of was but anyway Bryce
Dallas Howard loved working and kissing
Chris Pratt they worked together on
Jurassic world and she described him as
perfect in every way again not surprised
at all her on-screen kiss with Matthew
McConaughey came in a close second so
we're throwing it in as an honorable
mention she said she really liked the
way his mouth tasted after drinking all
of that fake alcohol tea is that TMI
never now let's talk about one that
didn't go so well on one side I anyway
it was incredibly awkward it was like it
was like some weird social experiment it
felt like even though she did say he was
a good kisser she did not like kissing
him or Rupert Grint actually they're
both like her brothers not the vibe
Daniel on the other hand to be honest it
wasn't too awkward it's quite enjoyable
um I I quite liked it there really are
two sides to every story another great
who knew moment these two have an
incredible Love Story Ashton Kutcher was
Mila Kunis's first kiss on the set of
That 70s Show and she was so nervous
because she had like the biggest crush
on him obviously she played it cool and
didn't want him to know though but she
played it so well that he really didn't
have a clue it's clear though regardless
that the feelings ended up being Mutual
I'm lucky enough to play her boyfriend
so I can make out with her oh and then
there's this steamy moment Sarah
Michelle Geller's character did some
unforgivable things in Cruel Intentions
but teaching Selma Blairs character how
to kiss was definitely not one of them
Sarah also revealed that this was her
favorite on-screen kiss and if you've
seen all of her performances like I have
you'd know she does a ton of on-screen
kisses when the two of them won the MTV
movie award for best kiss as they should
they recreated the moment for the
cameras and if you haven't seen the full
clip of their acceptance speech you
absolutely should it's hilarious and
totally iconic and they also have
continued to recreate that kiss for
years like check out this Instagram post
from 2020 and speaking of icons Jennifer
Lopez and Josh Lucas spilled every juicy
detail about their movie and Unfinished
Life including the intimate scene in the
back of a truck that was cut when asked
about her favorite on-screen kiss
Jennifer Lopez didn't skip a beat saying
it was Josh Lucas even though they were
both pretty nervous at the time I felt I
would hope he would say the same yes
that we had a very good kiss she said
the intimate truck scene was on
uncomfortable and he said he loved
filming it with her even though it ended
up being cut I see you Josh I see you so
this one is a majorly different vibe
than intense Love Story scenes in the
back of a truck Kate Hudson described
Heath Ledger as beautiful sweet and
gentle it's an emotional topic for her
not something she thinks about or talks
about much the movie in question is
called the four feathers and thinking
back on it she was nearly brought to
tears but says everything about working
with him was really really lovely Judy
Greer didn't hesitate for one sec after
being asked about her best on-screen
kiss Lily Tomlin hello they shared a
kiss in the movie Grandma which was just
in general one of Judy's favorites and
she wasn't shy about sharing her
experience with Lily on set and I have
to say she has very soft lips another
one that was mutually loved for both was
the kiss between Megan Fox and Shia
LaBeouf on the set of Transformers Megan
wasn't shy about how much she loved Shia
during that time and Shia told
interviewers how it would have been
nearly impossible to not be attracted to
Megan Fox due to how much time they
spent together plus like she's Megan Fox
I love I love him I've never been like
really quiet about that I I love they
were romantically involved during the
movie but apparently after the film
wrapped so did their relationship so a
little awkward but I guess not really
because this was many years later
regardless sorry Megan anyway Shia
LaBeouf says his favorite on-screen kiss
was with Dakota Johnson he was kinda
asked under pressure by Ellen DeGeneres
who his favorite on-screen kiss was and
after some hesitation he blurts out
Dakota Johnson calling her a sweetheart
but the next question in the interview
was about a most recent lie he told and
he said he just told one I see you Shia
I see you but what do you think you
think he was lying or just embarrassed
by how much he liked kissing Dakota in
the peanut butter Falcon oh and there
were deaths and Vibes for this one is it
possible that a non-screen kiss could go
too well these two were secretly married
shortly after the power of Sarah romer's
lips must be no joke what was your best
on-screen kiss
my wife they met in 2014 while filming
the TV series Chosen and got married in
2015 when she was pregnant with their
first child going through all these
kisses was a whirlwind from Ashton
Kutcher being Mila Kunis's first kiss to
being her husband today Sarah Michelle
Geller and Selma Blair being absolute
kissing icons and all these onset
relationships that I honestly could not
keep up with if I tried which on-screen
kiss is your favorite